et on va plus loin avec dans un instant
parmi nous Marie Roger billoha
directrice d'Afrique internationale
mediagroupe et à mes côtés gothierry
winsky chroniqueur international ici
même à France 24 bonjour Gauthier comité
d'accueil plutôt chahuté pour les
représentants de la CEDEAO la délégation
West africaine venu sonder les
intentions du nouveau pouvoir pucciste
du Burkina Faso elle a dû se contenter
d'un séjour bref séjour à l'aéroport de
Ouagadougou en cause des manifestations
massives dans la capitale burkinabè non
à l'ingérence de la CEDEAO non à la
France vivent la coopération avec la
Russie autant de slogans hostile à ce
qui est perçu comme l'ordre établiothier
oui l'ordre établi c'est celui qu'a
Corée établit la France et d'ailleurs
pourquoi pas les pratiques souvent qui
sont postes coloniales des rappels les
indépendances de ces pays ont été des
pratiques imitées des Français imités de
l'époque de la colonisation là où la
transgression cette la transgression de
l'ordre établi fonctionne très bien
c'est que si vous voulez les demandes au
fond les demandes de la population
bourquinabè ou autres à l'armée
française l'opération barkhane ou à la
politique entre la France et ces pays-là
ce sont c'était ce sont encore des
demandes contradictoires c'est-à-dire
des demandes à la fois de sécurité
notamment par rapport au menées
djihadistes que ça soit dans leur Mali
que ça soit au Burkina ou encore
ailleurs donc ces demandes là sont très
précises et dans le même mouvement le
fait que si vous voulez le reproche fait
aux Français de s'immiscer dans les
décisions de ces pays d'assurer une
présence qui est
10 styles et parfois ils ont raison une
présence qui a les aspects d'une forme
de d'arrogance coloniale et donc voilà
pourquoi on est avant debout contre la
France pourquoi aussi parce que je pense
que quand on a des moments qui sont des
moments extrêmement difficiles le nombre
de coups d'État dans cette région n'a
fait qu'augmenter c'est d'ailleurs pour
cela qu'on dit que il y a un recul de la
démocratie parce que forcément les coups
d'État à chaque fois sont commis par des
militaires et bien ce nombre de coups
d'État quand sa fragilise toute une
société déjà fragilisée par les segments
si vous voulez qui sont centrifuge les
forces centrifuges de la société ça
donne l'envie de se réfugier dans une
époque qui est idéalisée et quelle est
cette époque idéalisée alors Burkina
Faso c'est évidemment celle de Thomas
Sankara mais c'est aussi l'époque où on
a pris son indépendance par rapport à
qui par rapport à la France donc pour le
Burkina Faso ça date de 1960 et que
cette époque est magnifique dans la
mesure où elle représente quelque chose
qui était pensé tôt une véritable
indépendance un véritable une véritable
séparation de cet tutelle or le fait de
se rendre compte à Toro a raison du fait
que ça serait que cette dépendance
existerait encore et quelque chose
d'insupportable parce qu'on assimile
cette situation chaotique aujourd'hui à
cette présence
qui n'est qu'à moitié dictée disparu à
cette présence de la France c'est
manifestations elles sont l'expression
d'une colère spontanée d'une partie de
la population envers la France face
aussi à la dégradation continue de la
situation sécuritaire comme a dit le
capitaine pucciste Ibrahim Traoré ou
bien une manipulation des Russes
Gauthier
manipulation des Russes c'est difficile
à dire dans la mesure où l'objectif des
Russes n’est pas de gagner que mon on a
pu le dire ces dernières années par
exemple en Irak mais enfin c'est c'est
le théoricien italien Graham chic il y
en avait parlé ça n'est pas de conquérir
les esprits et les cœurs ce n'est pas
l'objectif russe les Russes se disent
quand on a une position sur place et que
l'on peut finalement aider un régime à
tenir le coup et bien ça fait tenir le
coup aussi à une population qui obéit et
puis dans le même temps on peut aussi se
servir au passage des richesses de ce
pays est-ce que donc c'est un sentiment
anti-français ou fomenté par les Russes
c'est encore une fois je pense la
réactivation d'un sentiment qui permet
finalement de créer un bouc émissaire la
France malgré son passé malgré son
présent en Afrique qui est parfois
encore une fois il faut bien le
souligner très douteux mais malgré ça
elle fait office de bouc émissaire pour
beaucoup de population ce qui explique
qu'on voit des drapeaux russes fleurir
dans les rues mais je ne pense pas que
cette population est la certitude
aujourd'hui ou ne soit consciente plutôt
aujourd'hui de
dans quel pétrin elle risque de se
mettre avec les Russes qui n'ont
strictement aucun alors c'est peut-être
ça l'avantage pour certains autocrates
africains mais qui n'ont aucun souci des
populations africaines ça c'est clair le
capitaine traoréen qui s'est engagé hier
au micro de nos confrères des reffi de
respecter le calendrier de restitution
du pouvoir au civil au terme d'élection
libre sans cesse dérouler au plus tard
en juillet 2024 écouter
on souhaite que le retour à leur
constitutionnels
pour un but particulier
les affaires mais on souhaite que ça se
passe le plus vite possible voilà on
vient de l'entendre donc c'est le chef
des puccins
il s'engage sur sa tenue de ce de ce
scrutin est-ce qu'il faut le croire
aujourd'hui
vous voyez bien ce qui s'est passé au
Mali alors c'est vrai que la pression de
la CEDEAO peut aller dans le bon sens
mais il y a amalgame par certaines
populations de la CEDEAO à cette forme
de pouvoir en forme de de théâtre
d'ombre de la France et ça ça fait aussi
peut-être capoter les initiatives de la
CEDEAO d'un autre côté on sait aussi que
la CDAO quand elle pense à pacifier ces
situations et c'est évidemment louable
mais elle pense aussi à ses propres qui
pourrait être contaminé par cette espèce
d'esprit dégagiste qui va aussi bien à
l'encontre de la France que de certains
pouvoirs remplacent après tout le
lieutenant-colonel labyba qui
représentait un certain espoir quand il
a été quand il est arrivé lui-même à la
faveur d'un au pouvoir et bien il
vient d'être chassé donc là il faut se
dire qu'elle est quel est le suivant
quel est l'étape suivante et en fonction
de quoi une jointe un pouvoir Pucci
sanctuelle aurait plus d'efficacité ou
d'audience que le précédent Marie Roger
billot à nous a rejoint en direct de
Yaoundé bonjour Marie Roger on évoquait
l'arrivée un peu chahutée la CEDEAO
aujourd'hui à Ouagadougou avec des
manifestations dans la capitale
burkinabè manifestation contre la
présence des représentants ouest
africains contre la France aussi et
favorable à la Russie on ne peut pas
dire pourtant que la CEDEAO est fait
preuve jusqu'à du d'une sévérité
particulière envers les militaires qui
ont pris le pouvoir aussi villes au
Burkina alors pourquoi une telle rancune
d'une partie de la population d'après
vous
alors vous savez juste même avant que je
vois tout à l'heure il y a quelques
minutes nous correspondant le France 24
a reçu la vidéo j'étais déjà David que
tout ça c'était un épiphénomène vous
savez c'était anecdotique par rapport au
poids et à l'importance de la CEDEAO
dans toute la sous-région et ça ça
contraste je peux pas m'empêcher de
faire un parallèle avec
les organisations sous régionales
d'Afrique centrale je pense à la SEMA
que même la CEAC face à des situations
similaires parce qu'on a je me permets
qu'à une parenthèse on a aujourd'hui au
Tchad une transition où le président de
la Transition le fils de lui a annoncé
qu'il allait prolonger enfin il a pas
annoncé lui mais il a fait annoncé qu'il
a des prolonger la condition de deux ans
et qu'il allait se représenter
contre ce qu'il a contre ses propres
promesses on a ce qui s'est passé à RCA
avec tentatives de changer la
constitution donc le problème le
chapitre n'est pas clos on n'a pas
entendu
Lama ni la CEA c'est alors que
la CEDEAO si on proteste contre elle
c'est parce qu'elle a une utilité parce
qu'elle est opérante parce qu'elle est
opérationnelle parce qu'elle a des
résultats et qu'elle pèse sur les
processus la preuve et la délégation a
été reçue et maintenant évidemment on
connaît la crielle de revendications de
l'implication contre la CDA ou notamment
sur ces processus démocratiques bon on
en a beaucoup parlé on estime qu'elle
elle est un peu un syndicat des chefs
d'État mais ça c'est
on voit bien qu'elle a elle pèse
lorsqu'il y a des coups d'État et
qu'elle essaye de revenir à l'ordre
constitutionnel même avec toutes les
difficultés on a vu que le Mali est et
maintenant aussi la Guinée se disent
qu'ils peuvent pas faire sans et qui
doivent quand même
appliquer et se soumettre un peu
je dirais à ce que veut la communauté à
laquelle ils appartiennent tous c'est
manifestations contre la CEDEAO Marie
Roger vous pensez qu'elles sont
spontanées de la part de la population
qui reproche semble-t-il à CEDEAO aussi
sa proximité avec la France ou bien y
a-t-il derrière une une manipulation
russe la question que je posais à
l'instant à Gautier revinsky
alors il faut pas tout mettre sur le
pont de la manipulation russe qui est
certes importantes on voit des slogans
favorables à Moscou et gagner primoji le
le disons le
fondateur de Wagner du groupe Wagner à
lui-même saluer l'arrivée au pouvoir de
ces de cette nouvelle jante
il y a eu le cas de la Guinée que tu as
pas Condé annoncé
la CEDEAO c'est montrer
ça cette partie là il y a des choses
qu'on reproche vous allez très
sincèrement à la cedea mais évidemment
moi j'ai été frappé quand je regardais
le le
comment dire le passage Trump de la
jinte de la nouvelle jante avec Ibrahim
Traoré et je voyais ce
fleuve de rideau rude de drapeau russe
c'est-à-dire qu'on est parti on est
passé des cartons où on avait mis des
couleurs russes ah maintenant une espèce
d'industrie et on se demande on peut se
demander d'où viennent ces jolies
drapeau en masse comme ça russe
évidemment qui sont là et c'est vrai que
la France a toujours envie de tout
mettre sur le dos de la Russie la Russie
est là elle fait tout ce qu'elle peut
pour prendre la place d'enfance pour
enfoncer la France
j'allais dire même c'est c'est la règle
juste de bonne guerre mais seulement il
faudrait que la France comprenne qu'il y
a de vraies grillettes envers c'est à
dire que là en ce qui concerne la
sécurité on peut dire ils disent tous
là-bas la France est restée de 2013 à
maintenant
au Mali on n'a pas vu vraiment les
résultats etc etc sauf que quand même il
faut dire qu'il y a une inflexion en
écoutant les manifestants qui étaient
très contents qui sont montrés
satisfaits de ce coup d'État dans le
coup d'État
on a quand même vu qu'il y a une petite
réflexion et que on est maintenant
carlassé attentif aux résultats de de de
vapeur qu'il s'agit au Mali on va voir
je crois qu'il y aura une désillusion
parce que
on sent que l'enthousiasme a baissé les
gens ce qu'ils veulent c'est des
résultats ils vont pas embrasser Wagner
juste pour passer le Wagner au début
certes pour embêter la France pour dire
les choses simplement mais à la longue
lorsqu'ils verront que Wagner n'est pas
une armée et que ils sont marrants
lorsqu'ils disent j'attaquent la France
ils disent que les néocoloniale et vient
exploiter l'Afrique
on voit que leur méthode sont encore
plus brutales et surtout qu'ils ont pas
la grande l'efficacité qu'on attend donc
ça on entendait déjà des commentaires un
peu plus mitigés par rapport à wagnais
vision on n'a pas à se soumettre
échanger de de comment dire de mettre
et de changer une servitude quand une
autre ça commence déjà à venir on en
parle j'ai un peu plus et on verra
comment on en parle effectivement dans
les dans les prochains jours et
prochaines semaines au Japon à présent
l'alerte aura duré 20 minutes et plongée
dans l'angoisse de régions du pays pour
la première fois en 5 ans la Corée du
Nord a tiré un missile balistique de
porter intermédiaire 4500 mètres dont
une partie un haut-dessus de la
péninsule japonaise Gauthier en quoi
est-ce plus grave que les tirs de
missiles que la Corée du Nord a effectué
à intervalles réguliers un désormais
plus grave même on s'en souvient que
c'était en mars de cette année le tir
d'un missile balistique intercontinental
sert potentiellement susceptible de
toucher les États-Unis parce oui parce
que celui-ci si vous voulez et d'un
usage on va dire un peu plus facile un
peu plus facile et plus rapide à mettre
en place donc ça veut dire qu'il est
c'est vrai que le le missile
intercontinental à quel bon il est il
est effectivement très dangereux et il
suscite une angoisse généralisée mais
celui-là si vous voulez à la capacité de
s'attaquer précisément à une puissance
régionale s'il s'agissait de l'intim
beaucoup plus rapidement et avec
beaucoup plus d'efficacité c'est en ce
sens que les Japonais ont réagi de
manière extrêmement épidermique et on le
comprend parfaitement c'est qu'ils sont
là à constater et à devoir constater ce
jeu entre la Corée du Nord c'est pas un
jeu mais c'est ces relations entre la
Corée du Nord et le reste du monde avec
une Corée du Nord si vous voulez qui est
toujours d'une certaine façon à
jouer un
une partie jusqu'au moment où elle ne
peut plus avancer sinon elle est obligée
de déclencher le feu nucléaire et que
donc à chaque fois on sait bien ce qu'il
y a derrière c'est l'approvisionnement
aussi en denrées alimentaires en pétrole
de la Corée du Nord qui finalement
semble aussi depuis longtemps préfère
laisser mourir de faim sa population et
mettre ses fonds dans les laboration des
programmes nucléaires est-ce que cette
fois-ci il sera possible de résoudre ou
de calmer la tension par justement ce
type de mesure ce n'est pas atteint le
problème d'ailleurs c'est qu'on ne
résout pas cette crise tout simplement
parce que la Corée du Nord est désormais
et c'est ça aussi pour répondre à votre
question qui est important c'est qu'elle
est désormais une puissance nucléaire
assise c'est à dire qu'elle a acquis une
technologie de base que chaque tir
confirme et valide et là et bien on est
devant l'affirmation d'une technologie
extrêmement précise et pointue Marie
Roger ont craint maintenant un nouvel
essai nucléaire de la part de la Corée
là encore le dernier remonte il y a 5
ans peut-on se permettre à un nouveau
front sur le terrain de la menace
nucléaire après Moscou était errant
je crois qu'on va pas choisir
c'est-à-dire lorsqu'on a affaire à des
acteurs comme la Corée du Nord
totalement imprévisible même si j'ai vu
ici et là on s'attendait à ce qu'il
fasse ici qui font qu'ils fassent des
tirs de missiles balistique il y a
quelques jours déjà on en parlait mais
globalement
je dirais que ils sont dans une logique
et illogique et on a eu un passage assez
cocasse avec Trump certains estiment
qu'ils ont je ne sais pas ce que Trump a
obtenu de
monsieur qui nous ont eu à part de lui
dire qu'il était amoureux de lui et
faire des photos et c'est organisé des
séances assez nerfs avec lui et
lorsqu'il était de passage dans la
région mais je trouve que ce qui est
intéressant aussi comme résultat de de
du séisme qui est la guerre au cœur de
l'Europe la guerre la Russie contre
l'Ukraine
c'est que
beaucoup de pays qui étaient qui comme
la le Japon ont des constitutions
pacifistes comment ça envisager
sérieusement peut-être de changer de
changer la situation on l'a vu pour
certains des
veulent maintenant
adhérer à l'OTAN etc et là le Japon même
si on peut se rendre compte que pas mal
de japonais tiennent à cette neutralité
ils veulent
mais
l'ancien Premier ministre celui qui a
été assassiné dans shinzoa B
parmi les griefs qu'on avait contre lui
et pour lesquelles on s'opposait à des
funérailles nationales où il y avait ça
aussi qu'il a essayé de casser la
constitution pacifiste du Japon
de l'Ukraine merci Marie Roger
effectivement le risque c'est bien sûr
la dissémination la course à nouveau à
l'arme nucléaire relancée par des pays
comme la Corée du Nord merci gauthierry
binsky merci à Marie Roger qui était
avec nous en direct de Yaoundé au
Cameroun on se retrouve nous dans deux
minutes pour un nouveau journal dans
Paris directrice avec nous
[Musique]